a little bit the impression that people
have sometimes well you're you're not
just a nice guy
you're like you're honest about your own
vulnerabilities which i've always found
fascinating
like you talk about what what makes you
scared you talk about what you're
worried about like you
you know like even this nick dance for
you like i am scared because i
i don't want to lose to this guy like
there's a lot of people who never admit
that
yeah but it make you i think it make you
stronger to admit that you're scared
because you're not scared to say that
you're scared
right someone who doesn't admit it
because he's scared
to admit that he's scared and scared of
himself he's scared of what people are
going to think
about him i'm not scared what people are
going to think they have to
to see me as i am so i'm not scared to
admit that i'm scared
and it's almost like when you don't
admit you're scared it's like you're pr
you're protecting yourself from evolving
because the only way you can ever
be realistic about a situation and get
better at anything in life is you've got
to
accurately address what's happening true
100
you know and there's some people that
don't do that and i think that cuts them
off
from a certain amount of progress in
life i think there's a certain there's
there's like walls that you put up
yourself because you're not willing to
look at your own failures
100 you're not uh you're not honest with
yourself
yeah so that's what it is a little bit
yeah so admitting you're you're
afraid is like so what [ __ ] yeah
you know what as much as i'm afraid i'm
gonna make that walk
the day of yeah the day of the the the
day of it and i'm gonna do it regardless
it sounds more crazy i would be more
afraid of a guy that says i'm
like who says like i'm afraid but you
know what i'm gonna still do it and i
don't care if i'm afraid
bring it i'll do it like this is sound
crazy to me more than a guy said oh no
no no i'm not afraid because this guy is
alive he's afraid to say that he's
afraid he's
right like man you know what i mean to
me like personally that's what it is
yeah the posturing and posing it's
unnecessary
exactly
[Laughter]
but you are afraid of aliens though
right